statues of Confederate heroes have been
removed from many public squares in
recent years now the target is a series
of murals portraying the father of our
country George Washington and is causing
a controversy in San Francisco John
Blackstone reports a passionate crowd
gathered for what may be the last public
viewing of an eighty three-year-old
mural in San Francisco's George
Washington High School
we need Paul safe to grow the mural
could soon be painted over in response
to complaints that it's demeaning and
his depiction of slaves and a dead
Native American at the feet of settlers
sure those who say this is no different
than taking down civil war statues in
the south they are out to lunch
former San Francisco Mayor Willie Brown
has known the mural since his daughter
was a student at Washington High one
complaint about it from
african-americans is that it shows
slaves simply being subservient simply
sitting there under the white man's rule
but that's the way America was but he
clearly was puttin on displays so that
we would all be for sure instructionally
disgusted with America in its slave
practices Russian born Victor Aronoff
painted the mural as part of the
federally funded Works Progress
Administration in the 1930s he was a
communist and a social critic Peter
Arnett oaf is his grandson was your
grandfather subversive in a way and what
he put into these paintings
he was trying to go against the grain of
their common narrative
portrayed in schools for those who want
the mural gone however pardon offs work
doesn't fit with today's reality after
complaints in the 1960s the school board
added another mural celebrating
America's multi-ethnic heritage
it was painted by artist Dewey Crumpler
who opposes the School Board's decision
this time the board should be able to
understand that they are there for
education not destruction of education
but the making of education and artists
education that is exactly what art is
supposed to be about period except for
apparently if you got elected the school
board you didn't get that class the
School Board says it will decide soon
how it will hide the mural either by
covering it with solid panels or feeding
over it but there are lawsuits in the
works and signatures being gathered to
give San Franciscans the opportunity to
vote in November on whether or not to
save the mural for CBS this morning
Saturday John Blackstone in San
Francisco what a fascinating debate yeah
it's so interesting to hear how people
are thinking about it yeah is it talking
about there's something to learn from or
is it a past you want to put away and
not look at right